it's lenski's 45th birthday today he's
getting a huge president Ukraine is
about to receive more than 30 M1 Abrams
tanks from the U.S military that's a
whole Battalion of our most
technologically advanced tank tanks we
said we would never send Ukraine now we
are here's Joe Biden
today I'm announcing that the United
States will be sending 31 Abram tanks to
Ukraine the equivalent of one Ukrainian
Battalion secretary Austin has
recommended this step because it will
enhance the Ukraine's capacity to defend
its territory and achieve its strategic
objectives
so Germany Poland and the UK are also
sending tanks
to Ukraine so what was going on here
well in a meeting of the Council of
Europe yesterday Germany's foreign
minister casually mentioned that NATO
has in effect declared war on Russia
here's annelina bear Bach explaining
that World War III is already underway
I've said already in the last days yes
we have to do more to defend Ukraine yes
we have to do more also on tanks but the
most important and The crucial part is
that we do it together and that we do
not do the blame game
in Europe because we are fighting a war
against Russia and not against each
other
now you hate to go with cheap historical
analogies but since this conflict has
been framed since day one by Our Idiot
class as a replay of World War II it is
fair to point out it's been a long time
since the Germans sent tanks into
Ukraine didn't work well last time
probably won't this time either but
that's what NATO is planning apparently
is numerous Biden officials have said in
recent Works weeks the goal is to take
back Crimea now wait a second at the
beginning they said let's just push
Russia back to pre-february 2022 borders
that seemed kind of reasonable to most
people including us
but taking Russian Crimea from Russia
it's essential port
well Russia has said many times and
there's every reason to believe them
that would lead to nuclear war but
that's the new plan was this voted on
that's truly crazy
and to do it we're enlisting one of the
most corrupt governments in the world
several senior officials in Ukraine
including the deputy defense minister
the top prosecutor have resigned because
they were too corrupt even for zielinski
now where'd all that money come from
it's a country of War it's been at War
for almost a year well the money came
from us because Congress has never
audited the money the billions in your
tax dollars sent to Ukraine
this is nuts but no one in Washington
seems to care
and we hate to pick on former CI
director Mike pompe was a nice enough
guy
but it's hard to resist responding to
this here's Pompeo telling us that you
have a moral obligation to give
zielinski everything he wants
we should be helping America and helping
America means a Sovereign Nation that is
prepared to defend itself from an
invasion and an attack where civilians
are being killed by Vladimir Putin is in
America's best interest for our economy
for our security we should be doing
everything the ukrainians are asking us
to do
okay we should do everything the most
corrupt government in Europe wants us to
do everything because that's good for
America
really that's the most important thing
we can do from okay we don't mean to
beat up on poor Mike Pompeo
but I mean are you serious
what about the armies of drug zombies
smoking fentanyl in every major city
should we do something like that
you're San Francisco right now
hey bro put this away man you got kids
walking out here man
dude really you're shooting in your neck
bro
that's crazy
come on man
what are you doing
come on man this kid's around man you
shouldn't be doing that around here bro
come on man you gotta go there somewhere
else man I'm serious bro you got to go
do that somewhere else he right in front
of a Starbucks you right in front of
Starbucks bro shooting up dope bro
so again if you had a to-do list of
things to do for America that might rate
higher
than sending more money to zielinski and
you might also since you were trying to
help America as Pompeo said he might do
something with the fact our Southern
border has been completely overrun by
Foreign Nationals millions of them
shepherded through into our country by
the Mexican drug cartels
but that's not the most important thing
in Washington the single most important
thing we can do is send Ukraine whatever
it wants to take back Crimea subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight